Breaking it down. Uh, you
know, smoke up. We help
through. It doesn't, I ain't gonna lie to
you. They do. Oh thank God it's legal now.
I didn't start until the after my
last, uh, to Leonardo. Really? Yeah.
First Time that I did,
but honestly it was probably like the
best thing they get it because I was angry
at the fight. I was angry at everything,
you know, I was like fuck, how can I,
you know this guy, I was like a 10 to
one favorite going into that fight.
That was the one fight with that never saw
much. I was like, don't you smoke them?
Uh,
so I just had this anger and the only way
I saw my dad can I deal with it was it
was alcohol. So I kinda turned to
that and you know that it's no good.
It's really, it's the worst way
to do it. Worst way to do it.
It just makes the delusions bigger.
You know what I'm saying?
It just makes you angry or in and it just,
it just kind of compounded everything.
But honestly like what have smoked weed,
it was like,
cause at that point like you know what,
I had tuned it out for so long because
that's what folks did that I kind of
associated with being lazy and
the hospice as well. And you know,
these fucking me to know,
you know,
I don't want to be using that because
on a corner. Right, right. Like uh,
but when I did it, it kind of
opened up the anger towards myself.
You know what I mean? It kind of opened
up my mind for the first time and, and,
and I think that actually did help a
lot of help with any, you know, I don't,
I don't like chronic or nothing, but you
know, I know what you're saying. Yeah.
I think that's what people were afraid
of with it too,
is that paranoia.
I would say paranoia is just you looking
at things realistically and even the
possibilities of things
happening realistically.
I mean some people for sure if they
have tendencies to be schizophrenia in
particular and then they smoke a
lot of weed, it could spiral them.
Cool. Yeah. Like anything else. I spoke
to my, it's not a good idea. And you know,
do doing too much of any one thing.
It's not a good idea. I mean,
he's the same way. You have to,
you have to be able to balance,
you know what I mean? You can't just
fucking sit on the couch all day,
but I'm glad
you're saying that there's a real
benefit to it too. There's some,
there's a benefit to it
mentally and exposing that
vulnerability and just making
you aware of who you really are.
Like maybe to other people.
We all,
especially men,
I think we puff our chests up and we like
to look at ourselves as a baby better
than we really are because
it's, it's, it's like a shield,
like a false confidence shield that you
put up to protect yourself from your
vulnerability. But marijuana
says, no, no, no, fuck that.
Why don't you just look at whatever the
fuck your vulnerability and stop doing
that stupid like this is, this is your
problem. This is what you're scared of.
You're like, shit, the weeds,
right? Yeah. It can help you.
Yeah. And it, and it Kinda a Alexa App,
especially after a fight. I remember it.
That really made me, that really helped
me to get over and not just get over it,
but to understand it and understand
what I was doing. Uh, because again,
you just don't, you know, you get that
the informal is maybe it's testosterone.
You get that fucking puppy, just
all, you know, you don't give a fuck.
That's the part of it for sure.
You know, it's just, it's also
think about what you're doing for
live in, man. I'm, it's the most,
one of the most risky propositions
you could do as a human being
outside of war. That, that too.
That too. And I, and I took
that and to, you know, you,
you obviously you take that
into consideration when you,
when you start doing something like this,
uh,
I'd taken into consideration every fight.
Um, you know, once slight one slip up,
you can be, you know, bad news. Sure.
Injury can take you out forever. You know,
especially when the EU was,
and when I was in my situation and
even when I was signed with the UFC,
it was like, okay, do I go
and try and be a doctor and
you know, or, you know, I was,
I was going into bio mat,
so I was like, I was really,
that seemed more secure.
You know what I mean?
That seems more like attainable easier,
or do I like throw caution to the wind?
And you know,
at the time when I was 18 or
19, uh, no, I guess I'm, yeah,
19. Uh, you know what, that was like
a hard, you know what I'm saying?
I'm one of those ones that was hard
for me to make, but it turned out well,
I guess,
you know, you're going to have
more than one interest too.
That's also part of the problem.
There's probably,
there's a lot of people out there that
like doing different things and you know,
you might be leaning more towards one
than the other and you just gotta kind of
soul search.